so the goal of my second talk is to
explain in more detail what the Lex
conjecture said how health minica proved
the Lex conjecture and what the status
is of this generalize like to conduct
your business that we already saw
yesterday in Michelle's talk so this is
all about this topic of determinantal
representations and we mostly talk about
symmetric ones by the end we'll also
talk about hermitian determinants
representations and so a determinantal
representation of a homogeneous real
polynomial is an expression of this
polynomial as the determinant of a
matrix where every entry of this matrix
has to be a linear form a linear
polynomial in the variables x1 up to xn
and everything is homogeneous for me so
the entries of the matrix have to be
linear forms and the result will be a
homogeneous polynomial in such a thing
for example can look like this this is a
determinant or representation of the
second-order cone essentially with this
extraneous factor so maybe the goal is I
would like to find a determinant
representation for the second-order cone
and then for some of you that sort of
easy to see that the determinant of this
matrix is equal to this
the simplest argument I guess is using
show complements you can do induction
along
stand along the first row or something
and you'll see that the determinant is
this point so already here right so
first of all this is a determinant
representation because this matrix is
filled with linear forms all of these
non diagonal entries that I didn't
specify are equal to zero but even here
as you can see there is this extraneous
factor of a linear form why is that
we'll get back to that so you can't
expect one you start with a quadratic
you would like a two-by-two
representation right and that's not
possible it's also an exercise but in
general for large and possible it's an
open problem with the smallest size of a
matrix is in this example which i think
is a particularly interesting example
not that the second-order cone is maybe
you know there are not from an
optimization point of view maybe but
from the point of view of being able to
prove any kind of lower bounds for an
explicit polynomial it's just you don't
have any good techniques I give you I
hand you the polynomial and I want
explicit lower bounds for this
polynomial we don't have any the
techniques so far to prove any so the
smallest size of the matrices they give
a determinant to representation of this
polynomial up to some extraneous power
of the variable X 0 is unknown even for
N equals 3 even there is a decision we
are particularly interested as we
already saw yesterday in what is called
a definite determinant representation
which simply means there is a value
there is a vector e if you specify all
of the X I to this EU get a positive
definite matrix easy to see that this is
a definite determinant representation
you can plug in 1 0 0 0 and you get the
identity matrix so this is a definite
which I'm anti representation we like
them especially because you can't do
this computation often enough because
it's the mother of all hyperbolic
polynomials
definite determinantal representations
or suppose and even though I think we've
done it twice already
how's it definite at the point E and the
polynomial P is the determinant of a I
want to show that P is hyperbolic in
direction I look at P of X minus T times
e is the determinant so it commutes with
plugging into
matrix first and then expanding the
determinant that gives you the same or
if you first expand and then plug in
this parameterize line now I use that
this is homogeneous of degree 1 so it's
filled with linear forms so this is the
same as the determinant a you plug in X
minus T times a you plug in e and now I
use definiteness to show that this is
essentially the characteristic
polynomial of a symmetric matrix a of e
is positive definite I can factor this
as B transpose B he's also a d by D
matrix of full rank and then this is the
determinant of right let's see
B transpose I want to pull it out so
there's a B transpose here then there's
a B transpose inverse a X inverse minus
T times identity do this right so if you
multiply this out you get a back and
there you get B transpose B now you know
you pull out things the determinant of B
squared which is just some constant
nonzero times the determinant of ax
minus T times the identity Oh II minus T
this is still a symmetric matrix so the
roots are real and this is a hyperbolic
polynomial that's really one of the ways
I think about this in various ways first
of all it's an algebraic certificate
that this is a hyperbolic polynomial you
can verify this identity by
interpolation for example and then you
have just have to check the definiteness
at the given point think of this as an
algebraic certificate that the
polynomial is hyperbolic or you can
think of it as a source of examples of
hyperbolic polynomials and so on and so
forth
okay so
in the Lexx conjecture was around so the
Lexx conjecture says in the special case
and we look at polynomial in three
variables only this is the only way you
can get a hyperbolic polynomial so every
hyperbolic polynomial of degree D in
three variables has a definite symmetric
determinant or representation and here I
make some simplifying assumptions that
don't really matter right I do a linear
change of coordinates to make sure that
my point E is the point 1 0 0 and then I
know because P is supposed to be
hyperbolic it's nonzero at the point E I
rescale the polynomial to be 1 so these
are some things I can arrange without
loss of generality for every hyperbolic
I make these assumptions because then
the determinant representation is
particularly nice and it's kind of
obvious that it's definite this if these
two assumptions hold then I can make one
of the matrices the identity and it's
the coefficient of x and then there are
two more just real symmetric matrices a
and B such that E is the determinant of
this real symmetric definite linear
matrix pets
and we will attempt to discuss the proof
of this it's easier to prove a lot
easier to prove if instead of real
symmetric you assume real hermitian and
definite or real hermitian doesn't make
a lot of sense
emission matrices instead of symmetric
one so you want a and B to be hermitian
they still have real eigenvalues it
still sort of the computation works out
but the proof is a lot easier so last
slide I hope I can give you a sketch of
the proof where these for this theorem
with hermitian instead of symmetric one
thing that's remarkable about the
theorem is you don't need any extraneous
factors here
well now Mae has degree D and I find
matrices of size D by D on the nose
correct so that's also another hard part
of this and yesterday we saw hyperbolic
programming and hyper Felicity cones and
maybe a question is I'll have a volley
programming and Saima definite
programming relate and this theorem
gives the answer for three dimensional
hyper felicity cones they're exactly the
same as three dimensional spectra he
drew cones and the degree of the
polynomial gives you the size of the
matrices the everything is nicely
bounded in the same
so but if you want to generalize this
you have to deal with these extraneous
factors and so one way you can certify
how Felicity and you can attempt to
write a hypervelocity code as a spectra
Hedra cone is by finding a definite
determinant representation not of the
polynomial itself but of a multiple of
the polynomial so I want to show I have
a hyperbolic polynomial P and I want to
look at the type of felicity cone I want
to show it spectra Hedra then the
algebra formulation of the statement is
the following I'm looking for a
hyperbolic poyomi Q such that the
product Q times P has a definite
symmetric determinantal representation
but I need the side condition this is
really a tough one this is a hard
condition that the hypervelocity cone of
this extra factor contains that of P we
saw in Michelle's talk yesterday it's
not so hard to prove that the
hypervelocity cone of a product is the
intersection of the cones and if I don't
want to hire if I'm interested in the
hypervelocity cone of P I don't want it
to change so the one the cone of Q has
to be larger it has to contain the
hypervelocity cone of people it gets
even slightly worse the statement the
generalize legs conjectures faults need
some extra hypotheses so this is true if
the poem is irreducible to generalize
legs conjecture holds whatever it is
you'll see it on the next slide you can
drop this but if not it's not clear that
you can drop this
a reducible what the definition is
it doesn't factor into my numbers of
lower degree so you mentioned that
Commission case is much easier yes it
one but let's put the burger the perfect
Commission it's not so on the full
equation do you know any application
which need needs this symmetric theorem
and Commission is not sufficient cause
for instance all application I
personally know including condition
single area Commission is completely
similar up to a factor of two of the
size of the matrices the same right
usually usually the sink is used to
prove inequalities okay because for for
matrices positive semi-definite much
easier okay
and you you have the same inequalities
for Commission descent the same stuff so
for instance all those like self
concordance follows from here mission
the same way is from symmetric so I'm
just curious I don't have a good answer
this dimension of optical as you say
yeah but I don't know if there's an
application where you really need
because all the application people are
taught to help the vehicle but it's
really to prove it probably often enough
to have and his name is I don't know
it's it's as easy
is spelt and
so let's elaborate on this extra factor
bit more because it's slightly subtle
and it's an essential part of the
generalized Lex conjecture so for
instance if you want to compute these
things see how to maybe algorithmically
compute them so I'm given a hyperbolic
polynomial up here it's a cubic in three
variables and it's the black zero set
projective picture in p2 with an
elliptic curve and it's hyperbolic if
you've not seen this before because
there's a convex oval and there's
another thing hanging out shows that
it's hyperbolic with respect to points
here if you come this is the hyperbola
city cone this is the section of the
hyperbola City and you may want to have
a determinant representation of this
which is guaranteed to exist by adding
Vinny cuffs theorem but maybe not a nice
one right they're hard to compute so in
this example I put the names of the
authors of the paper where I took the
example from it's hard to find the
correct factor here that makes this have
nice determinate representation and I
would think of this as relatively not
poor norms are right if it is simple the
coefficients are integers they're
relatively small and it takes some
tweaking to get such a nice
representation and here you see in this
picture the hyperbola city cone of this
linear form is one of the half spaces it
contains that of the original cubic so
this is also a proof that this cubic is
hyperbolic this determinate
representation it's definite for x
equals minus 1 y equals 0 that equals 1
one point in here
but these factors they need to show up
as you will see I think on the next
slide and it's sort of hard to control
them and hard to find them if you want
to do computations it's hard to search
over them and I will also on the last
slide give you a hint of where this
linear form comes from have to choose
another subtle curve here and then this
would be a line that has a meaning with
respect to a curve I didn't draw on the
picture yet so the clean statement the
easy looking one is every hyperbola CG
cone is a spectra he drew cone that's
the generalized Lex conjecture if you
want to phrase this edge brightly you
have to deal as I said I can't say I
think with these extra factors that have
to have these very control properties
they have to have a determinant to
representation of the product and the
containment of the high-publicity counts
so that's the algebraic tree formulation
and if you want to prove this conjecture
by sort of generalizing the health and
vinegar theorem you have to find the
queue and control this which is a non
algebraic property this is a semi
algebraic property which makes this
heart will see that these sort of edge
break part was done
now you Kumar gave a proof of this
without condition - so the problem is
really in part two
any questions about the conjecture it
looks very nice
so what kind of factors q seem natural
so we've seen already that sometimes you
can take a power of a linear form like
for the second-order comb there was an X
0 to some power sometimes this works out
but rarely another very natural choice
for this Q might be just the power of P
if I take a power of the polynomial
itself I don't change the fact that it's
hyperbolic because I just put
multiplicities on the roots along each
line and maybe that has a definite
determinant or representation there
would be very nice because I would have
a very controlled hue and this condition
too would sort of be easy to fix that
doesn't work out that will be a
complicated example first maybe let's
count why we need these cofactors at all
if we're not in three variables and
that's a very simple count what you do
is you look at the following map
so with this observation look at the
following map you take n-tuples
symmetric matrices
this takes D by D's metric matrices and
of them and produces a polynomial out of
this and variables
by doing the sort of obvious thing for
us if we don't care about definiteness
we take the determinant of this matrix
polynomial
essentially we want to ride every P in
this forum we even want definite and
what not let's ignore that for now and
it turns out that you get this bound on
the size of the matrices for free
because of homogeneity that I assume if
you multiply this out every monomial
will have degree equal to the size of
the matrices it might be identically
zero but you can get higher degree or
lower degree monomials because
everything to the Laplace expansion is a
product of linear forms so you pick from
every linear form you pick D many
variables so everything will be exactly
dignity that's an aspect of homogeneity
so if you think about stable non
homogeneous polynomials right the set up
is different for response to the fact
that I want homogeneous polynomials that
enforces the matrix size and now we do a
dimension count on things we know that
within this vector space the set of
hyperbolic polynomials has non-empty
interior the strictly hyperbolic
polynomials an open set so we sort of
know the dimension of the image of the
map that we desire and this is a nice
map it's a polynomial map and under
polynomial maps the dimension can't go
up it can only go down I mention of the
image of this map is at most the
dimension of this space and now you
count dimensions so on the right we have
n plus T minus 1 choose n minus 1 and
this is n times the dimension of the
space which is T plus 1 choose 2 so for
large values of n the degree is at least
2 or for large value for large degrees
in at least 4 variables there's no
chance that this will ever work out well
every polynomial can have such a
representation even without definiteness
okay so we need these cofactors for sure
we need to somehow manipulate our
polynomial to even have a chance to find
the determinant representation in there
our cofactors it will never work
that make sense
but what about this power approach while
that doesn't work for a subtle reason
and Petter found the corresponding
counter example it's a combinatorial
argument that I wanted to briefly sketch
so again you know remember from our talk
first half - vamos the basis generating
polynomial of the vamos Metroid is real
stable and homogeneous so it's
hyperbolic with respect to the positive
orphaned so we would like to have we
would like this polynomial to have a
determinant of representation but for
this one no power will admit one how do
you prove such a thing and this is sort
of a nice combinatorial argument
first key ingredient is that if you have
a multi linear polynomial you get
something like a pulley Metroid from
this observation
so given a P is hyperbolic in Direction
e
and I collect n elements which I call a
1 up to en in the hyperbola city cup of
P with respect to so I choose these n
elements so if I have a stable
polynomial for instance I can just
choose the standard basis vectors which
is like that's why I call them a1 up to
yet and you can do the following you can
define now the following function
defined by P that takes any subset of 1
up to n to a number
so what do you do Arpi of the subsets
you map it to the degree of the
following univariate polynomial in T so
you take your polynomial and you plug in
e plus T times some I in ser and this
out you get a point
in T the degree is the number you assign
to the subject claim is this forms a
what is called a poly majorities the
rank function of a poly mate
what the maître trial rank function of a
matrix tries to model linear
independence or spanning the dimension
of the span of some vectors matrix and D
by n matrix and the rank function of a
matrix the rank of sub matrices given a
sub set at the venue pick the columns
indexed by the subset asks you compute
the rank that's the rank function for
classical representable mate right well
Polly may try don't take a matrix why
did you pick only one vector assigned to
a singleton why not just a subspace so
you associate to every element of n not
just one vector in the representable
case but you associate a subspace of
some vector space and then the rank
function of the subsets is the dimension
of the span of the vector spaces V i4i
NS so the essential the important is
essentially a mate right but the
singleton gets not assigned a number
that's at most one but maybe something
else so the axioms are the same as the
axioms for matrix for rank functions of
Metro is except for this one assumption
that B rank of a subset is at most the
cardinality of the subs that's the one
axiom that you drop because your cell
faces to an element was slightly less
fancy but it's a somewhat over
functional yeah okay sub modular that's
the important accent somewhat yes I mean
for example I allow that all of them are
the same okay the silly fully Metroid
but otherwise not too much but a bit
okay so pull email you know you wonder
which pulley metroids are representable
by subspace arrangements and then you
have to sort of worry about some of the
properties they satisfy and the
essential ingredient here is called the
ingot and inequalities
I won't write them down there are
combinatorial inequalities that are
satisfied in the representable case and
you prove them by sort of dimension
theory engineer algebra they're not a
big secret if you have by that kept kind
of competent to write down so but every
pony in the colleges it's like the in
qualities for inclusion exclusion formal
get essentially conclusion I think they
call want fairness and you can prove the
musical parodies the for certain and it
goes up for certain ends really what
this what goes up even goes down yeah
for I mean they only hold for
representable in general they don't hold
for all polymatrix and in the
representable case is really dimension
theory in linear
and the point is that the poly Metroid
that you get from the Bombers Metroid's
does not satisfy these endings it is not
representable in a strong sense because
this is a certificate you can write down
you can pick subsets and they will not
satisfy English and inequality but if it
had a determinant a representation or if
even some power had a definite
determinant representation so you would
have determinant XIII it turns out you
could write down a representation of
this poly matrix by the following
subspaces so this is definite metric
mental representation then if you set
the subspace to be the range of the
matrix
this would be a representation a
realization maybe people use
of the poly Metroid associated to
of the power well you know you have to
take the multiple of the fully made road
you find over there
and that can't be true because it still
doesn't satisfy England inequality so
they cannot be a realization of the
fully metroid and this would be one so
why is it plausible that this would be
the right thing it's not too hard to see
because in if it's definite and stable
so all of the AI would be positive
semi-definite matrices so you can do
sort of this degree counting that this
gives you the right degree because you
add up
PSD matrices and the rank behaves nicely
if you add RPS deeming so that's roughly
how you argue this would realize
actually the pulley matrix because all
of the a eyes would be PSD and then
degree cancellations don't happen as
badly yes they otherwise can so it's
really this connection to combinatorics
to the England inequalities that makes
this counterexample work out so you
cannot always use powers of the pole you
really need a mysterious cofactor and
you need to control the
because you're not a little
impossibility for our the also Nielsen
for instance you have freedom to drink
positive coefficients so say you you
start with your brilliant or now you can
treat positive coefficient
they all have coefficient some
coefficient of zero this genius yes me
neither support istic and take power in
my dad won't give you the same because
the degree sink depends on them the
support yeah it's true but being stable
depends a bit on the coefficient no no
no okay you you have your polynomial
okay and you ask so you start with a
normal stable and UK you even don't care
but that we can do distress the bill so
it cannot because you want to help that
so you tweak you love two three
coefficients and take power and even
death won't allow you to get one many
times if there isn't one you can because
yes because get we can support not on
the actual coefficients
this is a very nice counter example
which tells us a lot about these
cofactors namely we need to really worry
about you can sort of if you want you
can tweak this example a little bit this
is degree four and eight variables if
you stare at it long enough you can get
an example degree four in four variables
let's not worry about this too much all
right so what do we do how do we find
cofactors how do we find determinants or
representations and there are some
curious facts if you have these
determinants or definite determinants or
representation some things tend to
become sums of squares that have no
reason to be so one of these curious
facts for instance for multi affine
stable polynomials here are the same
polynomials again in Pettus theorem that
show that it's stable right now if it's
multi f-fine is stable if and only if
all of these are non-negative so we have
no negativity of these polynomials in
the stable case if we also have a
definite determinant or representation
they suddenly also become squares of
polynomials it's a sort of matrix
identity computation it's relatively
straightforward but it's a very curious
I mean first of all they don't have a
reason to be a sum of squares and to be
a square is even more special
is one of these curious artifacts there
are more of them though so for example
in another paper it was observed that
these hermit matrices become sums of
squares in this sense
so whenever power of your hyperbolic
polynomial admits so now it's
homogeneous again admit the definite
symmetric determinant to representation
then these parametric Hameed matrices
that we have discussed factor as matrix
polynomials into q transpose times Q
where the matrix Q is not square or
anything it has some mysterious size
inside some mysterious number of rows
and it's filled with polynomials in the
excise also if you have a determinant
representation
oh you mean commission positive definite
polynomial matrix in one parameter yes
so this is generalization of essentially
of that one dimensional result in some
time point is the one dimensional result
is actually rather direct called
caloric moments to here so there are
many easy proofs yes I think you could
say such a thing
some of these other ways okay that's not
beer
things P
now you make me nervous I think P is
fine yeah P is what instead of so the
power disappeared that was part of
question there is no it's not the Hameed
matrix of P to the K but the Hameed
matrix of P but I think that's fine
presentation can be tested you have to
determine it to representation you know
that it's table you have this
factorization for the first unit let's
say you happen you happen to prove that
it exists but I'm just saying can you
test now on the stability so for this
class of for the class of stable
polynomials that have representation do
we get algorithms to test apparently you
need to find the certificate Q if you
have the determinant representation you
can write this as a square quite
explicitly you don't have it so what do
you know do you know that these are
squares somebody tells you it has it
yeah you can use a computer to find out
I don't think it gains you much if you
just have the secret information it has
one but you don't know anything more
about it I'm not sure it helps in
finding these squares
but conversely that's maybe why I didn't
get your question if you have such a
factorization you can attempt to
reconstruct the determinant of
representation and that sort of works it
doesn't quite work as smoothly as you
would hope but a modification of this
idea and a lot of details is essentially
the idea that Mari you had to prove
that's positive evidence that we have
for the generalized Lex conjecture if
you have a strictly hyperbolic
polynomial then there exists such a
cofactor Q such that the product has a
definite symmetric determinant of
representation but we have no control
over the hyperbola city college it's
again the condition to that I haven't
proved the conjecture yet because we
don't have control about the hyperbola
city cone of the cofactor and the
motivating idea is suppose you have such
a factorization you don't get them quite
so you use more general positive
transits results and then you get weaker
things and then you get such a Q in the
end by arguing very carefully but this
is sort of the starting point for
Mario's proof
I will not comment on this proof any
further mario will be here at some point
so this is the best we know since then
not much progress has been made about
controlling the hypervelocity Konev
queue right there is an exponential
lower bound for the size of these
representations that you need in general
so for the size of the matrices it's a
long theorem and a bit hard to digest
maybe so the essential idea is to prove
an approximation result in the hausdorff
distance so you are given hyperbola city
cone and you ask yourself how well can i
approximate this hyperbola city cone by
inspector ito accounts in the house of
distance this is what is meant by these
eight approximate spectra
representations vector he drew a
representation so this approximate means
in the house of distance of the cones
and then it shows that if you want to do
this for certain polynomials you need an
exponential size for the matrices
right as Kappa is an absolute constant
this 80s sort of also fixed and depends
on your parameters and then you get some
exponential is the degree and n is the
number of variables
it's bad to be but that's what it is
expect if you just expected the
dimension tailgate to work out yeah so
to surprising that it's exponential but
it still requires
so as Bradley it means if you want to
find this cofactor it has to have large
degree in general
so that's maybe attempt to see how you
would attempt to prove Helton binnacle
theorem and I will present a proof of
the hermitian case this is an element
more elementary argument this was worked
out by Daniel Pearlman and Cynthia Vin's
and it's based on something called the
Dickson construction and I will try to
point out what you need in order to make
the symmetric to get the full health and
vinegar theorem from sort of the similar
construction I will not discuss all of
the details for example I am sweeping
some generousity assumptions under the
rug at the moment that are not
explicitly stated for this to work as I
write this down for instance you need
that the curve defined by this
polynomial three variables is a smooth
plane curve and then you can do limit
arguments to deal with the case when the
curve is not smooth determinantal
representations in those cases by taking
the approximation for example with this
end path okay so but we're given the
polynomial P homogeneous of degree D
hyperbolic with respect to a fixed
direction that I know beforehand and I
would like to compute a hermitian
determinate representation that's
definite at the specified point e all
right and I will take a detour using the
adjugate matrix so I will not construct
the matrix a first I will construct the
educate matrix of a so the matrix of -
right almost maximal minors of maximum
what is not the determinant but the
other - okay why is this reasonable so
let me tell you roughly what's happening
so there is one very nice identity that
we learn in linear algebra and that is a
times the adjective matrix of a equal to
the determinant of a
this means something about our curve in
fact so if you have a point on the curve
where the determinant is equal to zero
then this is some matrix no and this is
another scalar matrix it turns out if
the curve is smooth that this matrix
must have Rank 1 curve it's smooth at
this point the determinant has a non
vanishing gradient and the gradient is a
linear combination of the T minus 1 by D
minus 1 minus so if the gradient doesn't
vanish because the curve is smooth one
of the miners doesn't vanish and this
matrix has Co Rank 1 which means this
matrix better have Rank 1 because they
multiply to 0 if the determinant is 0 so
that's why I'm after the adjugate matrix
because I know that on the curve it
needs to be rank one be a rank one
matrix this is what I will use to try to
reconstruct this matrix this it follows
for every Xyz
G of X equals zero educate matrix at
that point rank
and I assume you know the curve P equals
zero smooth playing
instead the key assumption the
smoothness in some sense if you want to
do this construction yes quick answer so
essentially the things which would
prevent symmetric no there are a few
more details I'll get to that so now
it's a bit much to digest now I want to
go through the following four steps
let's try to see what this is
so first I need an interlacing cut and I
can pick for example a directional
derivative of polynomial with respect to
a point in the hyperbola what I want is
I have my curve somewhere convex over
something else
what I need is an interlacing curve
which is the curve of degree 1 less and
it's zero that sits in between here
there's an oval there and then there's
some Wiggly thing they are always nested
if it's hyperbolic that follows from the
real roots along a line
maybe plausible but not as easy to prove
as it should be but you know sort of the
hypervelocity condition means whenever
you take any line through a point inside
here it only has real roots connected
components
so they're always nested in this sense
so I need to pick this red curve and
let's say I take a directional
derivative I could pick any other you
need this have a name okay it's called a
1/1 because it will be the top left
entry of the educate matrix I'm trying
to construct that's why I called it a
1/1 now I use Pazuzu serum I have this
black curve which has degree D I have
the red curve which has degree D minus 1
so they will intersect in the complex
plane in D times D minus 1 points zhuzh
theorem it's also assumed generousity
assumption that these points are
distinct that distinct intersection
points there's no multiplicity counting
happening here e times t minus 1
distinct intersection points now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to split
them up into two parts so half of the
points will go into s and the other half
I want to be complex conjugate to the
1/2 I picked that I can do because I'm
intersecting real cars so the whole set
of intersection points is invariant
under complex congregations or I can
split them up in this way
it one of the intersection points the
complex conjugate one is also one just
put it in s bar and then you keep
picking until you've sort of split them
up into two X and from this splitting
you're going so let's think about this
so the cardinality of s is going to be D
times D minus 1/2 if everything is
distinct right there's no other choice
and that we recognize as d2
now I want to look at the space of
polynomials homogeneous of degree D
minus 1 say complex complex polynomials
that vanish at least 1/2 of the points
that I picked let's do some numerology
I'm sort of claiming that there are D of
them will be the first row of my
adjugate matrix why is that plausible so
let's count things so these have degree
D minus 1 right so there are d plus 1
choose 2 polynomials of degree D minus 1
in total and I want them to vanish at
this many points let's suppose they are
linearly independent conditions to
vanish at these points and then this is
exactly D so the space of polynomials
that vanish at all of these points in S
has dimension at least equal to
follows in the end that it has dimension
exactly equal to D but I mean I can for
sure pick D linearly independent ones in
the south face turns out that this is
the correct dimension in the end but for
now that's not even important
just by numerology I know that I will
always find D linearly independent
polynomials of degree D minus one that
vanish at these points in s that I've
chosen but they have to have complex
coefficients now so now we've left the
real world and now we have polynomials
and complex coefficients so and as I
said this list of polynomials I now want
to be or mysterious reasons the first
row of this educate matrix I'm trying to
build now I'm trying to fill up the rest
of this matrix by this condition I have
over here I know that I want this matrix
to have Rank 1 along the curve so it's
2x2 minors must vanish on the curve so
they must be divisible by the equation
defining the curve and that's exactly
what I'm writing down here I want a 2 by
2 minor to vanish along the curve so it
must be divisible by the polynomial P so
I'm trying to construct this
so why does there exist now these things
so now we have to sort of check what K
is and what we have so there's one one
this I have this is my red interlacing
curve I have the entry one J and I have
the entry one K these are in my lists so
now I need to find this polynomial a J
comma a JK the fact that this exists has
the right degree is some fact from
algebraic geometry with the generousity
assumptions I stated it follows from the
fact that P intersected a 1:1 if all of
these points are distinct is a complete
intersection for instance well generally
if the curve is smooth that's a theorem
due to Max nota that guarantees that
this polynomial exists that I want here
this a JK there's a unique comment on
this in a second so now I claim I'm
happy now I've built I claim I can use
this for all the J's in case to fill out
this advocate matrix by this mysterious
theorem from algebraic geometry there's
a JK is uniquely determined and I can
compute it for every J and K and fill
out this matrix now you have to convince
yourself once they have the aggregate
matrix you reconstruct a linear matrix
polynomial so there you need one more
facts and the fact of life is that if
you take the aggregate of this matrix I
just constructed this will have two high
degree right I have a matrix that is
filled with polynomials of degree D
minus 1 now I take D minus 1 by D minus
1 minus this will have very large degree
the nice thing that happens is that it
is divisible by a polynomial namely some
power of the polynomial I started with
if you divide this out this is a linear
matrix polynomial and that's the one we
after that is the determinant of
representation
so this choice of X is presumably
important in the last step like the
choice of s context controlled some of
the properties of the determinant
representation you will get by the way I
chose it it will make the aggregate
matrix homies but this particular reason
for picking the intersection points
polynomial and the derivative that's
easy to see that you have to do this if
you suppose you have a determinant
these are special points by something
else
so now the question so now so you can do
this you can check that all of this
works out and this is sort of some
matrix lemma you get a definite omission
determinantal representation if you want
some more properties for example you
might want symmetric right then you need
some more control so the problem is if
you have this splitting of the points
here you have to go to the space of
point ohms with complex coefficients
because you are imposing banishing at
complex points it doesn't mean you know
can't expect it to be real
unless itself is invariant under complex
conjugation then you can find V topology
and that's the hard part
because if you want this set to be
invariant under complex conjugation and
you want this set to be its complex
conjugates they have to be the same so
every intersection point must come with
a multiplicity of 2 and that's the hard
part you need a what is known as a real
contact curve you need a curve such that
a red curve such that every intersection
point as much even multiplicity to get
from this construction as a metric
determinant of representation and that
is that that needs some serious edge by
geometry to show that such a contact of
always exists that's why you use theta
characteristic divisor so that's the
major contribution of Victor Vinick
Hoffs work to this whole business that
you can choose this with a contact curve
and then you can choose this as being
invariant under complex conjugation
which makes this real which makes this
all real symmetric and work outs but
that is non-trivial and difficult to
prove that this is possible and these
directional derivatives usually don't
give you that
they don't necessarily produce real
contact this construction actually
generates lots of different
presentations right by different places
of the red curve many of them I quit you
can do some what can you do so once you
have the determinate representation you
can act on it with unitary matrices so
many of them then they come in finitely
many orbits under the solitary area
finitely many orbits of these
representations under unitary action
what's up I think we've got instructions
place in the symmetric case they can
until there are are usually become
tassel a dragon what
that's the good it depends on the
context right you knew that the so you
start with the polynomial with
coefficients and Q I guess or something
right so I think the question is does
the video contact curve have
coefficients in Q also because then
everything you know then these
intersection points are ID numbers and
then the rest is linear algebra and I
think that's not clear yeah because it's
transcendental methods that are used to
show that this contact curve exists and
don't think you can control the
coefficients to be algebraic numbers
not that I know but Victor I guess
I guess bye yeah bye quantify
elimination that must exist right
because the village buying numbers are
real close field so such a
representation is guaranteed to exists
but that even doesn't mean that in this
algorithm there we're finding these we
will do and so on without computing s is
a very good question and I think it's
open if you get your hands on the
subspace without having to compute these
points that will be extremely nice
and this step for is some some very non
constructive thing or it's like you can
actually see what the it's fairly
elementary EP you have to do work no
basis computation this can be done non
algorithmic secret
so this is how you construct these
it higher you know if you want to do
this in more variables all sorts of
problems come up these are not points
anymore but intersection curves or
something in that
this is a very special aspect of this
construction that you hear I've set the
points and it makes perfect sense for
point numbers to banish one sets of
points and there are many subtleties if
you try to generalize such a thing there
are papers that use more fancy algebraic
geometry of how you can do similar
things in higher dimension but it gets
we need more technique to be able to
state these types of results that's what
I wanted to tell any questions
so this is outlined followed by Commerce
result also know he has it in more
variables rights we need them
[Applause]
oh yeah how many minutes why not